all right I think we're live pretty sure
we're live welcome everybody welcome
back thank you for joining me sorry
about last week came down with a little
cold so I wasn't able to hop on the
stream but you know it was honestly a
very great break it was a nice resting
period for myself and yeah I'm excited
to hop back in with you guys today I
hope everyone as well I hope everyone
has had a good two weeks it's been two
weeks since I've seen you guys um let's
see here so yeah we're doing we're doing
some cool stuff today I'm gonna be
modeling and texturing this newspaper
stand from these reference images I took
and you can actually download these
reference images there's a link in the
description below
and there's also a link to the discord
server below that's where you know all
of you guys join the discord server and
have a lot of awesome conversation you
share your work you ask a lot of good
questions and you can download these
assets in the announcements channel on
the discord server as well so we also do
a weekly challenge last week's weekly
challenge was jellyfish and we got some
really really cool submissions so I'll
be excited to announce the winners of
the weekly challenge at the end of the
stream but yeah we're gonna get through
modeling blocking out this newspaper
stand this is pretty basic geometry here
so this would be good for people who are
starting out with modeling or are
looking for ways to speed up their
modeling workflow and you know basically
from there we're gonna talk about
texturing and we'll talk about how to
get the texture and the surface
imperfections down so actually a little
bit of exciting news here let me
actually hop in and see if you guys
yeah greetings everybody hello hello in
the live feed what's going on
um yeah we're doing it so a little bit
of exciting news here so I am going to
be giving a sea graph presentation for
max on that will be coming up at the end
of July I believe the presentation is on
its it's it'll be titled something along
the lines of the secrets of
photorealistic renders and I want to
talk about the process or my process of
creating photo real assets and comping
them into footage that may seem
difficult or tricky at first and I know
I've done some stuff like this on the
stream but this will be a very focused
55 minutes from start to finish and
we're actually going to put this CG
object once we recreate the CG object
here I'm going to put it into you know
this footage here and I've always passed
these two newspaper stands and it felt
like there just needs to be a third one
right in between and I thought it'd be a
really good example of showing how you
can create something that looks photo
real that fits in the space and is
comped perfectly so you can't tell the
difference between the real one and the
fake one right so that'll be the topic
of the course will be hitting every
element down the line creating custom
HDR eyes surface imperfections motion
tracking normalizing your scene
compositing tips and whatnot so that's
that'll be my sea graph presentation for
max on at the end of July and we'll see
if I can upload that that video here so
I'm gonna be building out this asset for
you guys and doing a little bit of
pre-work for the sea graph presentation
live right here on the stream so in the
sea graph presentation
kind of it's gonna be an overview of
this process but you guys are gonna get
the full experience right now okay we're
gonna do this we're doing it live cuz
you know you can't get two hours of a of
a modeling thing live at a C graph
presentation it just takes too long and
yeah father's days tomorrow guys get on
it get on it get your dad something cool
tell me you love them Randy thank you
thank you
France it is a place that I have always
wanted to visit I will visit and I and I
really appreciate appreciate your
congratulations on the Maxon
presentation all right you guys are
saying let's do it and Petros what's up
dude longtime friend Petrus welcome to
the stream and yeah dude Petros you can
hop into blender man it's free it's it's
great you know these modeling tips and
tutorials and concepts all apply to any
other program whether it's free or paid
or whatever you guys can be using
anything that's that's another thing
guys is like it does not matter what
program you're using they're all
basically the same they all they all do
similar things they get you to an end
goal how that you to that angle will be
a little bit different because obviously
the programs are a little bit different
right your hotkeys are gonna be
different your buttons are gonna be in a
different place but when it comes to a
general workflow and when it comes to
completing something in 3d all of these
programs like Maya 3ds max cinema 4d
blender you know you can do anything in
any of these programs so don't get down
by the fact that this is a cinema 4d
tutorial and you have blender so you
can't follow along like get not get that
out of your head because you want you
want to be able to say as open as
possible
and learn as much as possible yeah
so let's let's jump in let's get started
you evolved our interactive thank you
for the super chat brother I appreciate
you thank you for joining I really
really do appreciate it it's it's cloudy
here in Los Angeles I got my ambient
music you guys can actually follow along
if you guys want to listen to some chill
ambient music there's a link to the
playlist down below in the description I
got my tea this morning and I'm ready to
go so let's jump in guys let's do this
thing again download these reference
images the links in the description or
in the announcements channel on the
discord server the link is also in the
description so follow along let's do
this together okay so the first thing
I'm look like it's a box right we got a
box I got a very simple setup here I
have an HDR eye background you know
loaded in through this in little
environment HDR environment which you
can find through I believe objects HDR
environment in octane I'm using octane
and scorned thank you brother for the
for the super chat really appreciate you
as well thank you so much as awesome and
thanks for the congratulations I'm very
very excited as well it'll be it's super
cool to be presenting with some of my my
CG heroes right it is pretty crazy it's
gonna be crazy
very excited but yeah I got a simple
HDRI background and then I actually have
another HDRI environment right and if I
go into the environment tag I have it
set to a color so this is an image and
this one right here is a color set to
black and the type is visible
environment so if I if I change it to
primary environment we're lighting our
scene right here we're lighting this
scene with a black image and obviously
you can't see anything because it's lit
by a black image there's no light but if
I change it to visible environment we're
gonna let our
HDRI shine through right and this is
just a the apartment here so it's a cool
way to get like a background going but
also have it lit with an HDR eye and you
can change that up for any color you
want you know if I wanted this to be
like blue or something you know or like
a draft paper or something like this it
can be whatever you want let's try it so
I don't have exact measurements I could
have gone out and taken a ruler and or a
measuring tape and gotten exact
measurements but I'm just gonna do this
by eye here I think it'll be okay I also
have this footage as a reference to kind
of see what's going on here how big this
stuff really is but let's just make sure
that we keep our shapes correct in
proportion to the other shapes so right
now we're looking at a rectangle right
with a beveled edge here that's the main
kind of shape of this box here now in
front we have kind of like a little
another rectangle in front right and
it's kind of Ken but it's connected to
the top so there's like a top piece here
and it gets a little bit more intricate
with this handle connected to this side
here so it's just pushing and pulling
polygons from basic shapes in our case
cubes right and it's all kind of
standing on this little pedestal here
right very simple geometry very very
simple you know and then you have these
nuts and bolts down here which will also
model and then of course the texturing
right you can get really fun with
texturing this thing and that's that's
my favorite part building it is really
fun but when it comes to texturing it's
like ooh you're bringing it to life
so this is pure ref this program here
actually is really cool I'm still
learning it but it's a really good way
to reference stuff it always stays on
top but let's let's jump in let's just
block out this newspaper stand okay
so first and foremost we got this cube
and we want it to first off I always
spawn a figure always get a figure
because then we know how tall this thing
is you know I'd probably say it's you
know we're gonna block it out that's
what we're gonna do it's probably about
this tall something along those lines
maybe a little bit taller but once we
like it doesn't matter how large or
small we model this as long as it looks
correct in proportion to itself then we
can scale it up and down you know for
the end of time and we'll be okay you
know we can scale it up and down but
let's start here
it's looking like this top shape here if
I were to come up here it's a bit
skinnier in this direction in the z-axis
so something along these lines I'm
actually hmm what's the best way to do
this cuz it's like you have this top
piece here that's well that's clearly
one piece and then you have kind of this
little like extruded shell piece that
looks like it's one piece you have the
door panel here which is one piece right
here and we're gonna do all this as
geometry moving over to the side view
here it looks like this shell piece
comes up here and wraps down around the
side
and again we have a top piece the shell
and then there's this little back piece
here let's see there's the back piece
yes which is kind of a separate it's a
separate object so this will be one
object here this will be another object
and then we have the whole thing of
course okay so it's kind of if I were to
make this editable and I'm just gonna
quickly model this I'm gonna hit MS and
that's gonna be our bevel tool and
that's fine we're gonna start moving
these lines around so I'm gonna go to
that side I'm gonna find that side view
reference again let's see here we go so
a little bit more than halfway up this
newspaper stand if I come into a side
view we'll hide our figure for now this
this is all about looking at your
reference and taking note of where the
lines intersect and what is actually
happening so this line this line right
here is a little bit more than halfway
up this rectangle so I'm gonna make sure
I move this and I'm just doing my eye a
little bit more than half way up right
here I'd say that's about nice okay then
it comes up to this point in it if I
were to draw a straight line up from
this corner it probably so right about
here is where it would be if it was just
a rectangle and it looks like it's
coming in by about a third
so one-third two-thirds three-thirds and
this feels about right to me where it's
at currently that feels about right so
next up let's say let's actually just
make sure that we have this okay from
the top and it's going to be built out a
bit more so this actually
looks like this is where our model is
right now is right here but it extends
and comes out a little bit so again
we're just roughing it out we're
blocking it out looking at the reference
asking questions where do things lie
where are things extruded we want to get
the shape of this down okay so let's see
here
let's keep going and let's work on the
next piece what do we want to do next so
we have this let's do this next so
instead of making a new cube right and
orienting it properly let's just go into
the polygon mode and select this polygon
here because it's lined up exactly how
we want this little piece to be oriented
so one thing we could do is we can
actually extrude this or we can extra
dinner or we could actually hit you p on
the keyboard and that's going to break
up that's how I remember that hotkey up
break up you're going to break up the
geometry so now we have this piece right
here and it's sitting right in place
right where we want it okay
so let's I believe on what the anchor
point in the correct spot so I think
that is the center axis - yes Center
access to that is yeah the center axis
to tool and that'll snap the anchor
point right into the middle of whatever
geometry you have selected which is
always handy okay so now what we want to
do is kind of grow the bounds of this we
know that this edge here stays right
that's flush but it kind of extends
beyond this rectangle here so if I just
move this out like this it's kind of
what it's doing and if we go to if we go
to the top view
right here we can see it comes out by
about that much again this is all all
from from the eye here and now we have
to ask ourselves does this extend in
like this or does it extend out like
this and I think it extends out because
I think that all extends out all of this
stuff I'm holding I'm holding control
and moving those polygons or moving
those edges out and it's going to create
new polygons which is exactly what we
want
now let's reference the side view again
and see okay so notice this top line is
flush like we have here this is flush
let me actually go to the left view just
to make things easier camera left so
yeah this is flush right here but this
bit it actually extends down and this is
a 90-degree angle okay so we need to
make sure that works let's go here let's
grab this edge holding shift grab that
second edge and I'm just going to move
this down to about that point right
there and that that feels about right
and then we'll take this point right
here and I don't know how to perfectly
move this Oh see how we're just getting
that one point like this we're just
moving this one we actually want to from
our side view you can go over to your
attributes page here when you when you
select your selection tool uncheck only
select visible elements and that's going
to get everything in its path
yeah so I don't know how to snap this
like I know snapping of course is a
thing but that's snap that's snapping to
the grid polygon snap axis snap yeah I
don't guide snap I don't know
edge snap it's still just going to the
grid you know the answer is probably out
there guys but I don't know it right now
so I'm gonna do this ctrl shift Z undoes
camera moves by the way let's see
I'll just do this by eye probably not
the ideal way to do this or honestly
guys like another another way we could
do this and actually get it exact would
be to delete this extrusion that we did
and we could grab let's see let's undo
that move yeah that's let's undo okay
I'm gonna take this and you see when we
select that edge we actually get the
correct orientation for the gizmo let's
bring that down okay and then when I
select those edges we get the improper
rotation here so what I'll do is I'll
probably just take this and extrude it
out so I believe that is MT shortcut and
that's gonna extrude out properly I
don't want this edge here so me I might
what does it create caps now let's see
yeah let's create caps let's bring it
out and then I'm gonna just delete that
face so now we know that's perfect but
we still have this to deal with so I'm
gonna grab
let's see I think we can grab the edge
up here and it'll still be oriented
properly yes there we go and we'll bring
it down until it looks about about flush
about there and I think that's that's
that's a little bit more accurate this
way okay sweet shutter Authority welcome
welcome my friend
good to have you shuttle authority we
have known each other online for
probably man since YouTube started which
is really crazy
okay
so continuing on here we just wanna make
sure that this looks right let's check
let's check the right side and see
what's going on here so it does a thing
where it actually comes up and in right
here so we need to make some cuts so the
best way won't be the best way to do
this hmm this might be a little bit of
like two steps forward one step back
situation let's yeah let's try making
some cuts here on this boom and we'll
scoot that over just a little bit and
I'll make another line cut like there
okay so this these three need to go and
we need let's see how was the best way
to do this so these edges here one and
two see the gizmo the world or local
deal is not working it's only working
it's working for this one so I'm going
to control drag this one up and we'll
control drag this one in
and I'm gonna bring this point oh boy
I think I can snap it to the point yeah
there we go those points are stuck
together now and then same deal here I
should be able to take this and snap
this bump to that point and then I'm
just gonna optimize all of this so I'll
control a I have 19 points selected and
if you guys want this little readout up
here if you hit alt V that's gonna bring
up your viewport settings and if you go
to HUD you can check all these boxes on
the left total objects total points
total edges total polygons frames per
second
a lot of good info for modeling or you
know basically whatever you're doing
here in cinema so we have 19 points
selected and if I hit if I optimize this
I'm hoping this goes down to like 16
points so I hit you oh and it went down
to 18 points and this we want these
points to be let's try and get this
right in there and we want these points
to stack on top of each other boom right
there and if we select all again we hit
you oh we should this point should go
from 18 to 16 okay I went to 17 two
points it's two points selected right
here why
maybe if we where's the
weld one point okay so that's at one
point and then we'll weld these points
this should be okay this is one point
now which is good that's what we want
fantastic one point one point one point
one point probably a better way of doing
that you know I'm not the modeling
master here but hey it's working so now
we have a basic kind of outline for that
little bit there and I'm gonna move this
forward just a hair so that we can
actually I'll turn off snapping move
that forward just a hair so we don't see
the lines behind it make sure you guys
save your work okay so continuing with
the blockout okay we have to keep
blocking this thing out we're not gonna
get detailed quite yet let's talk about
this piece right here
huh okay what is going on here it looks
like that's straight perpendicular with
the ground and this is lined up with
this angle here let's see if we have any
more info on what that thing is not much
but we do have this angle here so this
angle this bit here if I were to select
this face it looks like I can control
drag and extrude this
why does that not feel like a straight
line this right here does not feel like
a straight line hard to tell very hard
to tell um but yeah okay so I extruded
that and it looks like we have a piece
coming it goes beyond the top of this so
I think we're gonna want to do the same
thing we're gonna break this up so imma
hit u P with that edge selected or with
that polygon selected right and now we
have this new piece to work with right
here okay and this is magic solo this
plugin if you guys want this it's really
nice plug-in that I'm David Arie of the
octane Jesus told me about and it's
amazing magic solo check it out
okay so this goes beyond again beyond
the bounds of this deal so I'm gonna
just bring this up like that and we want
to extrude this so I'm going to go to
edge mode or a sorry polygon mode and
we'll hit em T for extrude and we'll
extrude that out I'm looking at this top
edge right here boom right there and it
looks like the angle is going down so
that's correct
this angle is also correct okay so it is
not perpendicular with the floor but we
are getting a weird huh I guess it
starts tapered here and it gets larger
by the time it gets down here so that
means we need to take this edge
and drag it out we want to make sure
that this stays flush something like
that I'm just doing that by eye cool and
since it's hollow we'll delete that oh
and we still have only select visible
elements unselected and you can see how
it deleted this side we don't want that
so let's make sure we check that again
delete and now we have that shell there
oh hello so we have this shell here
which feels about right to me okay and
then we'll do this handle right here
which let's see what's the best way it's
a rounded rounded edge so we'll probably
I'm actually gonna save the handle for
when we do it legit it doesn't make
sense to just block that out I think
we'll do it legit when we get to that
point so that's basically you know if we
look at our render view here that
basically feels like this box you know
we want to get the base well obviously
we'll get the base so let's focus on
that next okay everyone good so far yeah
little thumbs up action if you guys are
doing okay we're making our way through
this
so we got a window here once we get into
the detail stuff we'll get all that
going that'll be our next step we'll go
through and do a detail pass and that's
what's gonna really bring this stuff out
and then we'll do a final detail pass
where we actually get the nuts and bolts
and like a little handle and stuff okay
so yeah let's get this little base wrap
around here which to me looks like
basically if we take our original cube
we'll grab the bottom I'm gonna hit you
P to break up that's the bottom and I'm
just going to scale it up i'ma hit T for
a scale tool I'm gonna just scale it up
a little bit just enough to get past the
edges here the boundaries boom right
there and I'm gonna grab if I hold ctrl
and click the edge tool it'll convert
your selection to edges which is exactly
what we want because I'm gonna hit W to
switch to the move tool
I'll hold ctrl and move this up just
like that
awesome that looks really nice and then
I'll grab the polygon selection tool
i'ma hit ul we'll do a loop selection
okay and I'm gonna hit em s on the
keyboard and bevel that or extrude that
out you can see that we're not getting
what we want here we want this to be
connected so I'll undo that I'll go to
let's cause I'm on the bevel tool MTM T
is what we want that's extrude right so
we'll extrude that we can always work
these in and out later once we get into
the detail pass but that's basically
what we're going for is something like
that okay so that's that like outer ring
that's holding this together that it's
like a little pedestal that's standing
on
you know well bevel all these edges
later and now we want this base piece
right here it looks like we have a
couple little things here which we can
work in but let's get this base piece in
that's pretty skinny compared to the
actual box and I'm not going to break up
this polygon again because we actually
want a square I'm gonna spawn a new
square will will scale it way down or
not square it's a cube rather and I say
something like that um let's make sure
we are in the model mode here and we'll
just bring this down let's actually I'm
gonna take a look at the footage here
and see it's probably a little larger
than a third of the height of this whole
thing so with that in mind it's probably
somewhere like that I would say cool
I'll make the cube editable I'll go to
polygon mode and we'll select this base
polygon I'm gonna hit MW to extrude
inner and we'll bring this out probably
somewhere around there and we'll extrude
again MT for that thickness just like
that
it looks a little small so what I'll do
is with polygons with the polygon tool
selected I'll hit ul I'll do a loop
selection around here
I'll hit T for scale and we'll just
scale that up a little bit more and I
think I'm gonna actually scale up the
base by a little bit more - I'll do ul
for a loop selection on the edges I'll
hit T and we'll scale okay so you see
how it's scaling all the way down like
that that's not good we don't want that
we don't want to scale on the Y so I'm
gonna uncheck Y up here and now it's
just scaling on the X and the Z so just
scale a little bit more and that feels
nice to me yeah we're looking at our
reference here
cool so yeah we just blocked out this
newspaper stand and this will be a great
guide for us as we get detailed and we
can actually use some of this geometry
as the building blocks for our detail
pass and it'll depend on what it is like
the base I know will stay the same you
know we might switch out some of this
stuff but honestly I'm pretty sure we're
gonna use most of this let's just clean
up our hierarchy here and we can move
usually what I'll do is I'll put my
camera
I'll leave my camera let me put the HDRI
backgrounds
I'll hit alt G and I call that scene
well we can get like a sunlight in here
too which in fact let's um let's try I'm
just gonna spawn a Sun you can do that
through objects lights octane daylight
and whatever this line is pointing is
the direction the sun is shining so I'm
gonna just angle this down so now that's
shining down and I want to backlight it
just a little bit okay and then I'm
gonna hit W to set my gizmo orientation
to world and I'm just gonna give it a
little side light from like like this
for the back that's nice and then we
actually want to combine our sunlight
and our HDRI environment so if you
select the daylight tag here and you
scroll down you'll have this little
checkbox mix sky texture we'll check
that and that's going to use the the the
HDRI as your reflections and your
ambient light and it's gonna use your
sunlight as your directional light cool
umm the highlights are really strong so
I'm gonna go to my camera tag I'll go to
camera imager and I'll crank the
highlight compression and you can see
here that we actually save the
highlights you get that info back which
is really nice and I think just we just
need a little bit we just need a little
bit of it because those nice highlights
are nice
um cool yeah so let's start getting into
the detail pass of all this stuff yeah
how're you guys doing guys I got any
questions or anything I'm gonna take
three minutes to catch up a little bit
scorned again thank you so much for the
super chat I appreciate you very very
much
so I've uploaded the newspaper front
page to the general section of discord
feel free to use it heck yeah awesome
thank you so much when this thing's all
said and done I'll pop it in there maybe
we'll have time here on the stream
yay Chris that's awesome you're buying a
new PC for VFX and loving these
tutorials that give me so much
motivation that is such a good thing to
hear man I'm really really glad and I'm
I'm so excited myself
honestly I really really enjoy doing
visual effects and recently okay guys
this is me this is big it was big so a
lot of you guys know that the Unreal 5
demo was was released maybe a month and
a half ago if you hadn't seen the Unreal
5 demo it is incredible Unreal Engine is
a real-time like I mean you make games
in this program but it's also used for
film too if you guys have ever seen the
rebirth trailer from quick cyl using
Unreal Engine and all of their assets
right their assets the mega scans assets
come free with Unreal Engine which is
already free so in my mind I'm like I
would be so dumb not to learn that
program so over the last two weeks I've
been doing a lot of tutorials and
learning Unreal Engine in the hopes to
stream it for you guys here because it's
free it is the future and I really think
that as a VFX artist as a filmmaker we
need to know these things we need to
stay on top of the industry you don't
want to get left behind that's certainly
true you want to be on top of you're on
top of your game and Unreal Engine is
the future so I encourage you guys to
look into Unreal Engine it can seem
daunting at first but find like give
yourself a goal or something or maybe
maybe we'll do a goal together with
unreal but um yeah I'm trying to
recreate one of my photos with my buddy
just as a test and I I want to be able
to do photo real environments that's my
goal and to do it in unreal and
eventually release a game I think it
would be really cool to release like an
atmospheric game so that's that's
definitely a goal of mine
and I want to teach you guys and stream
it for you so we'll get there we'll get
there all right I um am i eating enough
apples I probably am not eating enough
apples an apple a day you know I'm not
eating an apple a day I'll tell you that
much do I have any um so Manuel's asking
if I've had any background in 3d / VFX
prior to corridor yes I started out as a
VFX artist that was like my thing back
in 2000 what is it two thousand eight
seven six 2005 is when I started doing
VFX yeah in 2005 so when I started doing
VFX in Windows Movie Maker and
macromedia fireworks and I was adding
muzzle flashes onto my airsoft guns and
I was a VFX artist but then I discovered
Video Copilot and that's when it took
off and I started in cinema 4d release
10 were in release 22 right now so
that's 12 years
wow that's pretty crazy yeah I switched
to 3ds max for six years I worked in
Maya for like three months
trying to figure out you know just like
what's the best program for me at least
and because there was a lot of great
tutorials for 3ds 3ds Max and not enough
for c4d I switched to 3ds max and I
stayed there for about six years because
Freddie Sam Nico Brandon they were all
using 3ds max at the time and when I was
living with them you know it wouldn't it
wouldn't have made sense to be in some
other program that I didn't you know
that I barely knew so I switched to 3ds
max and I learned a lot through them we
all learned together and stuff so I was
really cool
but then we recently switched to max on
c4d when max on actually approached us
and like hey we wanna hook you guys up
so they give us
copy studio copy of c4d and that was
about two years ago and I hadn't looked
back I loved cinema 40 so much it is
fantastic
yeah this is a little background a
little bit of background let's let's get
back in here guys so this what do you
even call this thing like jeez main
piece yeah this is our this is our main
and we have our base and we have I feel
like this is more of the base this is
the base and then this is the stand
Stan will be at the bottom and then we
have the like the I guess this is like a
like a hood I'd say and then we have
what would this be what would what would
this piece be I have no idea what what
function does it serve
does that open I'll just say I'll just
say handle for now
control shift click all that alt G and
we will call this geometry the octane
daylight will go into scene and let's
let's continue guys am I gonna switch to
Maya no I will not switch to Maya I have
too much too much time in c4d and I'm
learning unreal right now that's the
that's the plan
Xun akio's congratulations you switched
to c40 today any tips for fast learning
yes
find it like give yourself a goal I want
to create X I want to create Y whatever
and look up tutorials to get you to that
end goal make it small so like for
example and unreal I'm trying to
recreate one of my photos a small photo
and I'm looking up tutorials to get me
to that point that it's probably the
most direct way to learn otherwise you
can go to grayscale gorilla calm and
they have a lot of incredible cinema 4d
tutorials that you can watch that it's
basically how I learned c40 I design is
another good one that's ye ye like your
eyeball design or just keep hanging out
on these streams every Saturday welcome
okay so it looks like here we have these
frame pieces that come up
they come up and they go in this looks
like it's connected it's welded together
this is one piece that goes in like here
man right here this goes in same deal
so let's get the body of this thing
right okay that's the top all right so
let's go to edge mode let's select our
main bit of geometry i'ma hit K L this
is a like a knife cut situation okay L
is that what we want you u L is loop
selection K L should be why is this
okay I'm gonna select main I'm gonna go
to polygon mode control a4 select all
and hit uo to optimize and let's try
that one more time
k L huh wow that's weird
optimized mean at worse
I don't know why that is not do I have
to be in weird
that's super weird sometimes things just
don't work
very very strange yeah I don't know why
that's not working
so that's a loop path cut um
[Music]
line cut would work as well because we
can just hold shift drag done you know
you got your line right there I guess
I'll do the same yeah mmm is there a
better way is there a better way so we
want to cut along this whole bit so we
could just take this move this back hold
ctrl and move that back out and we have
our line and as for this part well
actually it kind of goes around both
sides so we want one going this way too
so if I select both of those move it in
hold control to move it back and now we
have what we're going for that's
definitely a janky cheat way of doing it
because for some reason the knife tool
or the loop path tool is not working see
there it kind of is going and I don't
know why it's not getting all the way
around do you guys have any fix for this
see it's only cutting just the back part
it's not cutting the front part is Erika
bi-directional cut is in the options
reuse cut restrict to selection I don't
want it I don't want that connect cut
edges it's a loop I want it to be a loop
yes offset edge proportional symmetrical
oh is it stop stop cut a ten gone okay
that's that's something
stop cut at pull Arne very generous of
you thank you so much I appreciate the
super chat I'm gonna get that orange
yeah I appreciate you dude thank you
thank you so much that's great
restart the program sometimes that works
maybe the vertices on the bottom are
disconnected let's let's let's zoom in
okay so vertices we should have I'm
selecting all we have one two three four
down here five six seven eight up here
nine ten down here okay okay so that is
what we want right here boom that's what
we want we also want a cut why are the
cuts just just nasty it's not a quad so
it won't loop correctly okay
what am i building I'm building a one of
these newspaper stands here
man okay so maybe I need a boy stop cut
a ten gone preserve curvature
I think I need to do it let's see I must
like both of these edges or fate I keep
saying edges for those faces here and
I'm a hop out of solo mode come in here
I'm gonna scale it in hold control and
scale it back out I think that's the
best way to do this is to make making
those cuts that we need and why it made
these I'm not sure okay
problem-solving that's all you do when
you do movie effects some just kill
those in hold control bring them back
out
cool so that gets us the back we also
want the front or I guess this is the
back right so let's go to this view and
I'm gonna move it make sure we get all
those points I'm gonna move it in
control drag out so now we have like
this little like foundation all these
foundational pieces right here to mess
with okay
let's also get we need more foundational
pieces these ones on this side so this
is one way to do it yeah we want those
foundational pieces to go up this way
so let's see weird why do we have
okay okay I'm gonna hide the hood and
the handle and we have the front part of
it we just need the the side part so I'm
going to grab all of these polygons on
the main part so all these ones right
here
these guys and we will move them back
control drag them come on
control drag them out cool so it looks
like now we actually have all the edges
that we need we got there in the most
ridiculous way okay I'm wondering here
so I'm gonna save I'm gonna save this
real quick I'll save this as an
iteration and I'm gonna undo because I
think I can actually fix this by making
a cut just one cut right here
there needs to be a cut right here so
let's see let's grab the line cut tool
boom
we made a cut right there and now okay
we actually want to make a cut through
all that so I'll undo and we'll go back
to our line cut tool options we want to
say restrict to selection hmm we wanted
to cut through everything visible only
let's uncheck that click once on that
point great so now we have a cut all the
way around this I think that's the way
to solve this and now KL I feel like yep
it works it works the way we want it to
awesome so I'm gonna make that cut imma
make that cut we'll make this cut here
and we'll get that cut there and that
does it for us that's what we needed to
do that was the correct way to go about
it awesome awesome
sweet okay so let's grab all of these
edges here holding shift to get all
these high set edge again all of these
faces all these polygons right in there
and we want to extrude them out some hit
em T and that's going to extrude out
this edge
fantastic
we'll go a little bit more yeah that's
nice
awesome awesome awesome now we should
also bevel these edges as well I'm
wondering if we should do that later or
now
let's try it I usually turn out to bake
in my bevels so maybe we'll save the
beveling for last
we'll do a bevel pass and yeah modeling
you'll see 40 is similar to modeling
with blender very similar programs Pavan
welcome thank you for joining the stream
my health is good I'm all good to go so
thank you for checking in alright here
we go
so we have the edges there that's
looking nice let's um so the it looks
like the glass is also something that is
on the inside of this so if I actually
come into the main section and we select
I think all the sides are made of glass
yeah I'll select all of these sides here
and I'll hit you P that's going to break
up the geometry we'll rename this as
glass and we'll go to main and delete
those polygons so now we have these
glass polygons in here and I'm actually
going to hit MT for extrude and we'll
extrude those in mmm what's the is there
a better way to do this
maybe we
hmm hide the glass for a second and
we're inside of the main geometry now if
I select all of these faces here on the
inside and I'm gonna hit em T and just
extrude them in like this I also don't
want to make sure I forget those ones
okay the normals are a lot are all off
so I'm going to align the normals right
click a line at normals UA and we'll
extrude that in so it has a little bit
of a lip to it okay oh I forgot a piece
so we'll align the normals again all
right fantastic and why is okay we need
to do that again aligned normals
it's not huh maybe I need to just do
this manually and reverse these normals
for these guys reverse what reverse
I am truly confused
these all need to be the same color
so all the ones on the inside need to be
blue and aligning normals is not working
I don't know why and let's say they're
all blue these ones are orange let's try
just reversing those normals so they're
blue that works that works that's fine
okay we're actually good now now we can
finally extrude these because they were
going different directions I'm gonna
extrude it in and I'll reverse these
normals so they are correct I'm gonna
hit ul and make sure the top here is all
correct so these are blue you want them
to be orange that is the correct color
for normals basically like we're on the
inside the blue is the inside of
something yes
so we want to make sure our normals are
correct so I've selected all those edges
gotta keep saying polygons
and we will reverse these and this is
just setting us up so that we can
texture properly and then now these are
all incorrect so we want to make sure we
get these sides here we'll reverse those
normals and it looks like the rest of
this is correct
now when the normals are reversed
basically it's like it doesn't know up
from down you need you need to tell it
the right direction and that's what
we're doing by reversing and normalizing
all the normal stuff okay we can save it
now that's fine let's hop out of the
solo let's go back to glass we'll bring
our glass back in and we're just going
to grab each one of these edges and just
push them in a little bit so we maintain
that that lip there push that in just a
little bit so we get that lip
sweet and going on the inside here we
actually want this to actually continue
all the way to the edge and this is
where magic solo is very helpful okay so
I'll just grow the bounds of that I'm
going to top view to make sure we're not
overextending ourselves and we'll grab
these guys and we'll move them back this
way a little bit and same for these
front edges
holding shift grab both of them and I'll
just move those forward just a little
bit so now we have this glass here and
if we if we just make like a specular
material on octane we drop those on then
we're yeah we're good to go and you can
see it looks like the the UV unwrapping
is a little weird so we would just
change that when we get to the texture
but I'll leave it like that for now and
I'm just gonna hide the glass in the
viewport just so we can kind of get an
idea of what's going on here so yeah you
guys can see here where we're moving
along making our way and this is a
process so are you guys doing all right
doing okay so far
how's everybody doing in the chat here
all right Abram I'm learning unreal from
a multitude of places mostly from
YouTube and unreal
like learning site basically if you
download the epic games launcher you can
go to the learn tab and you can learn
from there we all get along in the chat
y'all I think they were all solid
answers that's the whole point you know
everyone's helping each other out when I
can't so it's alright to just chill out
and you know enjoy the Saturday so
what's next let's get the top piece
let's get this top piece going okay so
let's go to the base no not the base the
main okay and the top piece is let's
let's see it's a combination of the hood
and the handle piece or it's a
combination of the hood and the main bit
okay so it's what we want to do is
combine all of these top polygons
together so I think what I'll do is make
a plane I'm gonna make a new plane and
I'm gonna bring it up to the top here
and I bet you there's a way to get the
exact top going so we can see this is
twenty three point one nine one inches
on the Y that's where that piece of
geometry sits 20 twenty three point one
nine one we'll copy that we'll paste it
on the plane and nothing okay make sure
you're in the actual like the model mode
here and paste it on the plane and it
doesn't work
okay that's probably because it's all
relative um well heck we'll do it by eye
then that is okay right there sitting
right on top I'm gonna go to the plane
I'm gonna set the width and height
geometry segments to 0-0 let's bring
this in again by eye front and back as
well okay
so just about there covers the whole top
okay so I'm gonna make the plane
editable by hitting C you can also hit
this button up here it's gonna make it
editable so now we can make some cuts
and stuff I'll go to edge mode I'll hit
K L and let's make these cuts right here
and right here cool
and we'll delete this face right there
I believe that deleted there we go let's
hide our handle and our hood so now we
just have this top piece will go to
model mode
we'll bring it up just a little bit
awesome so now we know we need to select
all the edges here so imma hit control a
to select all the edges I'll control
click control drag and click these two
edges and I'm going to control drag down
and that's gonna get us our our like lip
here our top now we want to make sure
this is correct here I don't know
exactly what's going on on the inside of
that and you may it may not even matter
because our handle and our hood is gonna
cover that bit but let's just take a
closer look for a second here
also it looks like this is split it's
not connected right here you can see
they're all kind of inset the metal is
just folded around and it looks like we
have some holes punched in through here
but in fact I'm just gonna say don't
worry about it and we'll get those
screws in later
all right so let's undo that there that
drag down because I want to actually
have these be little separate pieces of
geometry here so I wonder if there's a
way we can split that up what would be
the best way I feel like you can just
control drag this down and if you look
down here we can see there's a there's a
number that correlates to how we drag so
we'll say right there point point eight
negative 0.8 coal and then we'll take
these two points
holding shift I'm gonna hit T and I'm
going to scale them in just by a hair
like literally right there is just
enough now let's go around and do the
same for everything else so I'm gonna
hold ctrl and I'm gonna type in negative
0.8 in the for the Y and I'm going to
scale this in by just a little bit
something like that it's I feel like
that's we might just want to move those
points instead that way we have a better
a better handle on it there and there so
that's very very fine detail but I feel
like it'll all kind of play out in the
end here so let's select these holding
ctrl will type negative 0.8 and then
we'll go to point mode and we'll get
these points separated just a little bit
awesome and we're gonna keep going
negative point-eight
I don't worry about that corner let's
get this guy control-drag negative
point-eight and the reason I'm doing
this one at a time is because it's the
only way I know how to like get two
points down here to mess with now this
piece this back piece is made from two
edges control-drag
negative 0.8
sweet
awesome alright so now we have our top
piece you can see that these pieces
these little frame pieces they actually
go on the inside of the top so what we
could do is actually just extend the
bounds of this top piece we'll drop the
plane in here we'll call this top
let's go to the top view here real quick
and I'm gonna go to point mode I'll grab
the rectangular selection tool let's get
let's see where are we yeah let's get
all these points on the side here and
I'm just gonna move them over so they
just go beyond the edges right there yep
and I'll do the same for the back these
points here
great so that's going just beyond
and did not wait a second did I do this
all wrong oh my god I did this oh boy
I did it the wrong way this is supposed
to be missing not this this is supposed
to be there not this piece ah so dumb
okay is there a way I can save this can
i salvage this I bet you I can
let's delete all of that and let's take
this
let's take this edge here I guess would
be this hole let's delete that edge
let's take this edge control drag it out
like this yeah okay no not a problem
let's bring our hood back in so I mean
how far we have to go and I just guessed
it perfectly sweet let's delete this
face and let's go back in holding shift
to grab both of those we'll drag this
down negative 0.8 and we'll make our
point adjustments here control drag
negative 0.8
and the back here it looks like we don't
need anything but we do need something
on the side here so I'm going to grab
the side edge control drag down negative
0.8 and we'll make sure let's go to the
rectangular selection tool go to point
mode grab all these points scoot them
over so it goes beyond the bounds of
these little frame pieces the vertical
frame pieces and then let's take these
points here and split them apart ever so
slightly these are the micro details
that I think will really stand out and
you got to put a lot of time into this
stuff but it all pays off cool
fantastic now we want to extrude these
little panel bits here because they
actually have some thickness to them
right if we go to our back to our
reference if I find a reference picture
or a reference image here you can see
there's some thickness to these panel
pieces and before I do that actually
this handle let's make a slice here and
[Music]
right in here if I hit KL do I have to
maybe we have to do the knife tool so
let's go to the top grab the line cut
hold shift that's one then we'll come
back let's see we'll come back for two
right there and I'll take that polygon
boom delete it
cool so we can move this around
depending on how our handle is when we
model that later but again let's grab
all these edges here holding shift to
grab everything great and let's hit em T
for our extrude tool you can right click
and find extrude right up in here as
well and we'll just bring these out just
a little bit yep that's what we want
fantastic sweet awesome awesome so we
got our top piece looking nice
and again we're gonna go back in for
beveling because that's gonna be it's
gonna be a nice detail that's really
gonna help our edges shine like
literally it'll it'll catch the light on
the edge of your model which is always
what you want
all right what are you guys saying here
um my advice would be to learn as many
different software packages as possible
to give you a bigger chance of landing a
job Chronos says to be honest blender
should be your main focus as a beginner
it's free and after mastering the
interface it's quite trivial to apply
technique into other software it's great
advice to add to that learn the craft
and not the tool all of these things I
agree with guys um yeah I I always think
you need to grow your value so the more
programs you know the better off you are
I do not think it is a requirement
though I highly doubt it's a requirement
now working for a studio I cannot say
because I'm not working for a giant VFX
studio who knows what they require but
I'm sure if you have you know knowledge
in a number of different softwares
chances are the software they use you'll
have you know it's kind of like you're
just upping your chances they probably
use a lot of their own in-house software
as well and if chances are if it's a
studio they're probably using Maya and
yes if you are beginner
there's no reason and if you're beginner
and you want to learn 3d there's no
reason not to download blender it's free
right so if that's your goal then
certainly check out blender because yeah
it's free and it's a super powerful
program there's no denying how amazing
that program is ok let's work on let's
actually just make sure we had
everything - the nuts and bolts for our
topper piece and it looks like we do
it's pretty simple geometry there next
let's get let's take care of this like
hood piece with this main door I think
that's gonna be the next biggest
challenge
okay
so let's bring our hood back in and see
what the heck is going on here so we
have this door piece right here
right that's some interesting geometry
it's you know you have these edge pieces
that go around this way this is all this
is all connected so we want to I think
we want to extrude that and have these
seams here with actual geometry this
panel is just on its own it's chilling
and let's see well model the inside
later the inside is a car you taken care
of
but it looks like on the base if I take
the hood off I think we can delete this
face from the main piece because I'm
betting that this is all there's only
one piece of glass here once you open
this door you reach in and you grab the
newspaper but the sides and the back are
also covered in that glass so three
sides are covered in the glass the hood
let's see if we select the hood and we
delete everything that isn't the hood so
it's just that little outer bit it looks
like it's connecting how is it
connecting to this it looks like it
actually has a back but it's or no or is
the back
okay
yeah I guess it's extended down here I'm
just trying to make make sense of this
let's not worry about the back for now
let's focus on the door okay the framing
here around the edges right here let's
focus on that for a second okay so I'm
gonna use these edges all around our
hood holding shift to select them all
and if I press T and hold ctrl I'll
scale everything in now you can see that
the top and bottom are being scaled
properly and we have to kind of go in
here and move these points around
they're not
I'm wondering if there is a better way
to do this let me undo I don't and and
not delete all this stuff so if we
select all of that and then we hit MW
extra dinner we can bring these bits in
that's kind of what we're going for here
we want to create that border that frame
around everything that feels about about
right to me and now if we delete them we
have this frame here right around
everything cool all right so from here
this actually continues up this way
so maybe we undo that and I'm just kind
of thinking out loud here
maybe we do everything but that
so we scaled this in and we're doing it
we just want to take note of how much or
extruding so where's my extra dinner
tool it should be up here my attributes
here we go okay
so the offset value of one point one
eight let's just call it one point two
and I'm gonna select this bit and we'll
do the same we'll go in by one point two
now we're getting double here on the
side which we don't want so I might just
have to take this edge and scoot it over
by one point one two so you can actually
type in on the x value minus one point
one point two and that gets us the edge
we're going for now I bet you there's a
a better way to kind of streamline the
geometry here
so I'm wondering if we can control a and
optimize this UO
and it looks like we want clean geometry
we want clean cuts on all of this stuff
so maybe let's grab let's go to the
front and grab the knife tool the line
the line cut tool and I'm just gonna
make some cuts around here where I think
we need some cleaner geometry
so right in there up there
cool what's going on here
a little funky return snapping on
we'll get those guys right
cool
and down here looks right to me
[Music]
I'm wondering if I moved something up
here that didn't need to be moved maybe
I think I had it right yeah that's cool
sweet okay so now we want to
select all we're gonna reverse normals
so it's facing the proper direction and
this is gonna be glass here this this
plane right here will be all glass but
let's take care of that in a second
let's extrude out these edges here
right all that stuff needs to come out
but I also want these seams here is when
we bevel I want to see these seams so I
might actually have to extrude these bit
by bit
hmm
so we can probably lose that edge I
think there's a way to disconnect well
I'm wondering if let's see that's one
point one point I think there's like
doubled up points along this
yeah there's two points in there so I'll
weld this where you at
oh yeah weld yeah right down there boom
so will weld that that's one point and I
believe there's two points up here there
should be two points up here yeah
two points well weld that as well
I think that's the only bit with two
points should be
and I should be able to disconnect both
of these
or dissolve is that what it is yeah I
just I just don't know I just don't need
those edges there
so I can actually use the bridge tool
here and then we can delete we can try
deleting this bit and we'll try the
bridge tool is it gonna work here yeah
that works nice and clean and we'll do
the same up here delete that and bridge
to there
awesome yeah that's clean that's clean
now this will save boy this is work guys
okay continuing on so we want to extrude
these bits here and honestly we can
probably babble them because we want we
want them to come in just a little bit
if I select let's see um yeah let's give
this a test let's select just this
corner here I'm gonna hit MW or no m/s
that's bevel and it's going on crazy
let's turn off snapping so it's beveling
but we want to not preserve groups and
we want the offset like yeah point point
one inches something like this you know
what I mean point one is even too much
point oh two five perhaps will get us
what we want in the extrusion we can
call just 0.175 or point point one
inches well guess what we want so we
know we need to extrude by point one and
offset by 0.025 so I'm just going to go
through here hopefully we can click and
just hit enter and nope that's too easy
we're gonna click and I think we just
need to go up here and just hit enter on
one of these values
and now we definitely want to do so we
want to do this as one group here so M s
for the bevel tool I'll check preserve
groups and then I'll hit enter so you
don't get that like this effect down
here where it splits the metal you're
not getting in here because it's not
there in the actual reference moving on
we're going to this top piece so this
top piece is actually the biggest piece
so it's a combination of looks like all
of those pieces right there so I'm gonna
bevel that M s and we want preserve
groups checked white enter it'll do its
thing but it didn't do it oh it's
because this is already done okay so
let's just undo back to that point and
go through and just do our due diligence
here we can do this one and we can do
this side one here
the rest is connected made up of like
multiple parts so let M s boom right and
then we'll come in through here we'll
grab these bits and those bits hit m s
enter cool and then same for this bit
over here ms4 bevel and we have all of
our inputs set
awesome so now look at our render you
see these seams that's what we're going
for these seams right here in the
corners you can see these seams right
here in the corners totally what we're
going for awesome okay so now what shall
we do I feel like this top bit needs to
come down some because it looks like
there's like some extra bit of geometry
up here for the door to actually hinge
on so what we'll do is let's see
we're not my stuff go
here we go
all right so I want to slide these
points up top I wanna slide them down to
make room for this little extra bit of
geometry back here so we'll go to hood
will go to point mode and I'm going to
make sure that only select visible
elements is unchecked and I'm just gonna
grab all these points in here holding
shift
let's see we kind of want to detach the
hood from the door so I'm gonna go in
and do a ul loop selection on the hood
but it looks like it's selecting
everything so I'm gonna just do this
manually real quick make sure only
select visible elements it's checked and
I'm just gonna go around here holding
shift grabbing all these polygons and
I'm gonna hit you P it's gonna break up
it's gonna separate those polygons from
the actual from the actual main hood
piece here so let's go to the back to
hood well delete and then now we just
have this bit here as the hood and then
the hood had become our door
so let's rename this to door and let's
hide the hood for a second
great now so now this door is actually
detached and I want to get the angle
right here I don't know how I don't know
how I know we can come in a side view
and just eyeball it but and it's
probably not gonna be that hard because
we have this guideline here so maybe
we'll just bring this down like this it
should be fine I'm gonna bring it down a
little bit more right to save room for
that geometry up top in the reference
that you guys can see
cool
and it looks like it's just a cube yeah
that's honestly it so let me grab this
edge I'm gonna hit you P it's gonna
break it up
and then I'm gonna hit MT for extrude
and we'll extrude this up and I'll come
back in a side view here and we'll just
get this right and get us right up in
the corner here and I'll just move these
points by eye making sure only select
visible elements unchecked so we can get
through everything
we'll get it right in there
and let's bring that let's see I think
the hood should cover let's bring it up
to the top so this will go all the way
up here into our hood awesome and then I
want to make room you see how the hood
here actually it's partly gonna be
easiest to there's a gap right here
those gap between the door and the hood
so I want to make sure that that we
actually have that gap and allow the
shadows to kind of come in there so we
could either move the door polygons or
the hood I'm just gonna move the door
polygons come in the front view
rectangular selection tool with point
mode selected and I'm just gonna scoot
these in just a touch just the touch
same for the bottom here I'm actually
let's do the side just a touch and this
side here just a touch and we'll do the
bottom and the top can stay and you see
there's this like cylinder here with all
these rivets that's what the door is
hinging on we want to get that in there
as well and it actually looks like
it looks like this cube goes past and
all the way out to the right side so
let's make sure we grab these points on
the cube here
and we move them all the way over to the
right awesome
man all you guys arguing about programs
dang
hopefully it's constructive doesn't
matter what program you use guys and
also like whatever works for you
seriously whatever works for you guys no
point arguing over what program is what
is better it's kind of pointless in my
opinion
use the best thing for you that's all I
can say if you have money to buy
something then go for it give it a shot
if not go with blender blender is
awesome anyone who says blender sucks
her planners not good enough well you're
wrong
just go look up Ian Hubert's work look
up Peter Francis work hopefully your
mind will click quickly be changed
okay let's get that cylinder in here so
we want a very small cylinder going
throughout this little top piece here
this is such small detail work but it is
necessary let's rotate this cylinder and
I need a grease here and we're gonna
make it the radius point one inches
let's bring it up and we'll bring the
height down and let's go into the front
view to see what's going on let's move
it around we'll Center it right up in
the area where we need it right there
and then we'll grow the height a little
bit more based on the reference see it
doesn't quite get it all the way across
but it gets most of the way as far as
the rivets go we're going to use the the
segments in the geometry to get that so
we'll fit that right in there and let's
actually move the cube
here let's move this up so we have a
nice little gap in here for us and we'll
grab this these polygons here for the
door and we move them up to give this
thing room and let's go to our cylinder
and just check how many segments we have
basically we want to get in here I don't
know if you guys can see this yeah right
in here we want those segments to be
apparent
those little riveted pieces so I think
what we'll do is we'll take the cylinder
we'll give it rotational segments we
don't need that many probably eight
rotational segments
maybe maybe twelve and we'll take the
height segments and we'll break this up
to like 32 and you can already see how
we're starting to get this segmentation
here across the way and now what I think
we'll do what's the best way to do this
make it editable and let's control a so
everything is selected and we might have
to just go through each one of these and
bevel them ms and they each need an
offset of like negative 0.1 what about
0.01 0.01 we'll do it in an extrusion of
0.01 as well somebody hit you l MS enter
ul MS enter and I'm sure there is a
faster way of doing this
this is we were doing today
you can probably do this with a cloner
you set up a cloner system for this but
I'm only halfway done so technically
that take me longer but it'd be more
adjustable but you can see in the render
view is actually giving us what we want
you can see the segmentation and we'll
see if I have time to get to the
texturing today because the modeling is
quite taking quite a while I definitely
want to be here all day need to enjoy
some of the some of the outdoors you
know again I'm hitting ul for a loop
selection m/s for the bevel tool
clicking inside of the bevel options
hitting Enter to guarantee we get the
same effect across all of these
cylinders here guys
ul MS enter ul MS enter learn your
shortcuts this would be taking a lot
longer if I didn't know my shortcuts a
lot longer you want to be able to get to
the end result as fast as possible while
preserving as much detail as possible
and again depending on what you're doing
you can skip steps
but for me since this is for a sea graph
presentation I need this looking nice
and let's render the region there
and I think with a little bit of ambient
occlusion we can get those cracks coming
out a little bit more so what we can do
now actually I want to give it a bit
more room so I'm gonna go back in the
side view and make sure this cylinder
has enough space
awesome all right so now we have our
door well again we'll do the screws last
let's get the hood looking right
definitely need the hood in there so
let's bring the hood or actually let's
rename some of this stuff so I'll call
this cylinder will call this hinge
that's for the door the hood
yep that's the hood the handle of course
the door this is like door mount door
door hinge mount I'm just going to group
all that and put it in the door
okay
so let's get that hood going now the
hood if you look closely in the
reference has a bit of thickness
everything has a bit of thickness
there's no such thing as just a flat 2d
plane all right everything has thickness
it's actually made from a couple
different pieces of welded metal I'm
gonna skip that step
or else I'll be here until next
Christmas so let's just go into the hood
and give it a very simple extrude here
okay so let's grab I'm just going to
shape this a little bit here
bring this down a little bit I'm gonna
make sure there's enough room around all
of this
cool cool
and then I'm going to delete that that
face there and I'm going to bridge it so
we just clean up the geometry
boom nice and clean awesome so let's
select control a will select everything
then we're gonna hit em T for extrude
zoom on in here see we're doing and
we'll extrude outer towards the outside
there and we just make sure our normals
are right so we're gonna reverse those
normals we want to make sure our normals
are correct on the inside those are
wrong so let's let's actually try
control a right clicking and align
normals and that should unify everything
and it did and then we'll reverse it so
now everything is correct
awesome things are starting to look nice
here guys we want to cover the back
right here so I'm gonna grab that's
actually before we extrude that let me
grab all of the edges here on the inside
okay
mighty for scale and I'm hold ctrl so
we're gonna make new polygons or make
new faces here holding ctrl does that
scale it in just like that I think is
fine now we just need to watch out for
the top and bottom ones so I'm gonna
come in here how what's the best way to
do this let's see
all right yeah so that retains great
okay that retains the orientation so if
I can control drag that bit that's gonna
be messy maybe we do that and we hit em
s or we can be bevel that edge maybe MW
now maybe it can we extrude the edge oh
okay
does that work I can't tell no see I
want to get this bit to all just move
towards the middle of this but
Jamie appreciate you joining us yes I am
well I feel better
oh it's cuz I don't know why selected
that's why that does it for us though
that gets us that nice dark edge that
we're going for that inset in here and
actually you know what let's push this
door back even more let's see what let's
see what the edge looks like we're gonna
go back to the reference here and you
see this is a dark inset this goes back
further so I'm gonna get that to go back
further but I also want to make sure
that the side view works too so maybe
it's a thing where we just closed
polygon hole so we right-click closed
polygon hole select that hole and if we
solo this let's just move that back on
solo and now in our render it should see
I think we need to move it back we also
need to move it down by a little bit
yeah so I move it back a hair and then
down a hair and then there we go
you can see that nice dark edge around
everything
and I think we can bring the hood and
the handle all forward and we would need
to go to our top go to point mode and
extend the top a little bit yep and then
yeah it looks like the top is just
coming out beyond the hood there and now
we can go to our hood and actually
extrude those edges so I'll select all
those edges
just like that it should be everything
that we don't want the back we just want
the ring selection here let's solo it so
we can see exactly what's going on and
we should be able to hit MT will zoom in
here and we'll extrude this now the
normals need to be aligned as well so
I'll extrude that just a little bit will
control a to select all will align the
normals and then we'll reverse the
normals
and it's coming together it is coming
together now we can go to the sea we'll
go to the door or this is like the yeah
it's still the door or the flap and
we'll delete these polygons here because
that's going to actually show us the
inside of this thing now the hood we
have polygons here that need to be
deleted so we need to cut a hole right
in here so I'll take this polygon what
mw2 extrude inner and i'm just going to
take this bottom bit move it up that
doesn't work let's see maybe we can
so I'm trying to cut a hole to get to
the actual reach inside of this thing
and reach the newspaper so I believe
it's something like like this and then
we have let's see a line cut probably
here and there so that leaves us with
this middle piece that we can delete and
we'll bring this polygon down to
something like that
awesome and I'll give this an extrude
just this piece here
something small mt4 extrude we want to
align the normals perfect awesome this
bit on the left needs to scoot in
we actually select that whole ring and
just scoot that just this bit let's
scoot that in
perfect perfect perfect perfect
sweet
fantastic
so let's model this handle real quick
right here so probably do this with hmm
we'll do this with some turbosmooth in
here and it looks to me like we can draw
this with a spline from the front view
so to me this looks something like let's
see
something like this
and we'll get in here just edit this a
little bit use the Move tool to adjust
these what do you what are these things
called these little busy a lines you
know
so I'm just getting the profile of this
right and then I'm gonna come in to
let's see let's solo it right and then
I'm gonna hold alt and I'm gonna throw
this little extrude what are these these
aren't model are these modifiers and now
these aren't modifiers these are I
forget it forget the terminology here
yeah it's thought a little extrude on it
it's going in the wrong direction and
way too far so we'll just set this to 1
inch and we'll go direction we will go Z
all right so now we have something like
this now we just need to let's actually
go to the spline let's set the
intermediate points to uniform and let's
set the number 2 16 cool and then let's
see I'm wondering if I can bring if I
just throw a turbosmooth on this thing
whoa that ooh that's rough
this is not the cleanest geometry here
it's a very small detail
so I'm wondering can we instead will alt
G this so it's in a null the extrudes in
a null I'm a hold shift with the null
selected and drop a bevel modifier in
here and let's take the offset down to
point 1 now this edge is getting chopped
up here so I'm actually gonna adjust the
angle threshold so it's not getting that
bit can we just do like 90 degree 0.01
0.05 0.04 and subdivisions like 2 or 3
you
and I'm adjusting the Fong angle still
making that edge look a little weird
yeah I'm just kind of like kind of
jegging this thing in there I think
that's fine though for what it needs to
be it's so small so I'm actually going
to select all of this right click and
connect objects + delete that's gonna
get ready everything I don't need all
these tags I'm gonna delete these tags
ok and then we'll just call this handle
and I'm gonna get the Anchor Point right
so let's go to model mode the Anchor
Point is nowhere to be seen so I'm
actually gonna use the center axis to
tool and that's gonna get it right in
the middle but I want it right on the
bottom here so I'm gonna use this tool
here the axis Center tool and I'm gonna
just set the Y to negative 100 and it's
gonna drop down to the bottom most point
of this model which is exactly what we
want because let's get out of so low and
let's move it over by any means
necessary and get it in place here we're
going to rotate it 90 and some number I
don't know yet we'll scale it way down
and we'll get it in there and then we'll
go into our side view to make sure it's
actually flush to the side of this thing
which is very close I think I aced it
again beautiful okay that's perfect yeah
it's right on there
so now we'll come in here and I'm just
double-checking that it's actually
sitting on the surface of that and now
we can actually move it around like this
because we move the anchor point on the
bottom we can scale it down we can scale
it up but it's always going to be
staying flush to the model to the
surface of that because we changed the
Anchor Point and
the anchor point right so let's figure
out where this thing is it looks like
it's in the bottom corner and it is
about at the halfway point
so let's make sure we got our move tool
selected and we are at local orientation
and we'll get this right in there it
needs to scale up a little bit so
something like that is perfect beautiful
let's get the handle in there and let's
see what this thing looks like right now
let's get a ground plane and let's move
our geometry let's actually set the
center access tool once again we'll use
that to snap everything the bottom will
include children and CUDA logics
executes that's gonna get the y that's
gonna get the actual gizmo down here at
the very bottom base portion of our
newspaper stand and then I'm going to go
down here these X Y Z values and set the
Y to zero so now it's sitting right on
the floor make sure we save our work
will scale up our plane and it's very
very bright I'm gonna get rid of the Sun
and that's not looking too bad I'm gonna
get rid of the glass here and I'll give
it a glossy material let's go with
something like let's go with this red so
I'll say that the glossy and we'll take
the roughness up by like 0.2 and let's
actually use the color picker here and
get this nice cherry red on the side and
that was for the roughness so we want to
undo that
what does roughness default to color
wise let's find out
roughness defaults to black okay cool
we're good so I'll just make sure you're
in the diffuse section here and get that
cherry red now we can start to see this
thing is coming to life based on our
reference
the handle I believe is chrome so let's
just make a quick chrome material and
octane very easy make a an octane glossy
material you can hit shift C and cinema
to make anything you want find anything
you want so you can make an octane
glossy material that way double-click it
go to index set the index to 1 and you
immediately have a chrome mirror surface
and we're gonna use that for the handle
here yeah it serves our purpose there
and then we have a darker material for
the actual base of this thing so let's
control drag out our material face was
covering down here let's go in and let's
set the diffuse to point one across the
board let's go point o2 and that gets us
closer to that dark that dark color so
you you could be done here but we still
have work to do here guys we need to
actually add the bolts we need to add
this little back handle piece in the
newspaper itself let's get the base with
the black material as well
awesome how's everybody doing you guys
thumbs up you guys doing okay do you
guys have any questions I'm gonna take
like five minutes here just take a
breather and we're gonna wrap up this
this model here I don't think I'll have
time for texturing today but that's okay
I got other tutorials on texturing so
it's all good specifically the studio
ghibli tank as well as last week's we
talked about custom textures or I guess
two weeks ago
sweet
we got one thumbs up Martha Martha arts
is modeling himself right now
fantastic we're gonna go into substance
painter awesome awesome yay artistry is
having a good time what I think of
Houdini
I only know Houdini as a magical program
that is very difficult to use I I did
one tutorial one Houdini tutorial
alright I followed one rather and
basically the tutorial tutorial was
saying it's not like any other 3d
program it thinks in a completely
different way get ready hang on your
britches and that's where I stopped I'd
rather spend time learning unreal so
that's what I've been doing recently
he's learning Unreal Engine I should add
more thickness to the middle of the
handle I probably should probably should
do I know that do I use another tool for
texturing no I'm just then octane right
now I think learning substance painter
would be wise I should probably learn
substance painter but again one program
at a time
Oh Tyler Moran wait the Tyler Moran okay
if you are the Tyler Moran then prove it
okay that's all I'm saying right now
prove it and thank you for the super
chat
that's a weird coincidence if it's
another Tyler Moran because Tyler Moran
is one of my very best friends my
childhood friends
we built a cardboard tank together and
made a video called cardboard warfare
I'm still waiting for that for that
comment here Tyler
is it you is that thee Tyler I need you
to prove it I'm waiting oh my god
he just texted me alright he texted me
proof okay it's it's Tyler let me go let
me show you something that Tyler made
for me it's the greatest birthday gift
of all time I'll be right back
this right here okay
now let me see this right here deserves
full screen okay
we're going big is a handmade butcher
knife hand forged butcher knife that
Tyler made for me yes Tyler I do have a
little rust on it but I still use it I
use it very often and right here in
Japanese it says create that is the
coolest thing ever like what a birthday
gift hand forged guys by Ty Lee Moran
himself Tyler Moran was the one who
called me one day and said hey Clint you
want to build a tank and I was like yeah
and a year later we built the tank I
mean we didn't wait a year it took us a
year off and on of course you know cuz
we had school everything and god man me
and Tyler have been on many adventures
we climbed a huge mountain together we
ate apples under a blanket together man
that's what else we would we would fight
each other we would wrestle all the good
stuff yep apples under blanket of course
how can I forget I'll never forget dude
I scrub the rust off it's hard all right
Tyler it's hard it's like you leave
water on that thing for two seconds and
it rusts that's awesome Tyler what are
you what are you doing here man we
trying to learn some 3d are you still in
San Fran
but Tyler we're making this newspaper
stand today it's almost time to add the
bolts I feel like that's gonna be oh
that's gonna be the fun part but we just
got to do this little handle bit last as
well as the newspaper stand on the
inside let's get the newspaper stand
done it's gonna be so easy it's just a
freaking Cube guys scale it down w/e and
are those are your that's how you cycle
through Oh ER and T apologies er and T
that's how you cycle through your
different move scale and rotate tools
let's just get this cube in here it's so
easy just enough so it fits just enough
so it fits and then we'll scale it so
it's a little thick right and we'll get
it probably right about there all right
and then I know one of y'all made a
newspaper for us in the discord server
is it an FBX that's textured I'm not
sure let's find out general oh my
goodness how on earth well I've got the
actual newspaper that's super cool
that's really cool yeah got the actual
how'd I get this on the air screen let's
just save the image so we got the actual
image here of the newspaper which is
sweet
so I don't know I feel like the easiest
way to do this is to go to polygon
though and actually I think they have
newspaper models already so let's let's
see I'm in full screen mode okay there
we go I'm gonna go to a website called
polygon comm and we're gonna go to
models oh my goodness the added stuff
yes this is great look at all these
plants look at these succulents oh my
goodness this is what I need oh yes oh
man this is the best this is the best
thank you Andrew price if you guys don't
know the blender guru he owns polygon
he's the CEO of polygon this is so good
guys these these uh these models who are
super high quality there's some of the
best and they work with all of your
renderers too but I think there's a
newspaper in here somewhere
there's only if there's a small amount
of models they have it's not a whole
bunch it's not like mega scans but the
quality is definitely through the roof
here was i imagining the newspaper
I was not it's sitting right here and I
own it I own it already perfect okay let
me just go there let me find it and drop
it in I'll show you how easy this is on
VFX materials 3d models polygons
newspaper oh one
all right and we open it up and copy it
over let's go
boom right in and we got a newspaper
let's give it let's give it some
dynamics simulation rigid body we'll
take the cube right click simulation
collider body hit play boom and it's
sitting perfectly right there
let's select both of those tags and
we'll set an initial state go back to 0
and we are set I'm wondering if I can
just delete those and yep it's it's
right there it's perfect
how perfect that is I was fast ok
let's go back to our reference and wrap
up this model Tyler I'm really glad
you're here man I miss you I miss you
maybe you left already but it's ok this
is all good what's this giant spring ok
so that on the sides here there's these
giant Springs that's wait on those let's
finish the rest of this thing so this is
actually very simple this geometry here
[Music]
let's call it's actually organized a
little bit so we got a floor I'll drop
that into our scene folder our cube this
is our newspaper base and of course we
have our newspaper so we'll drop that
into geometry and then we have our let's
see our handle is that yes I'm calling
it handle it's not really a handle and
we need to adjust it so let's grab this
polygon and move it down just like that
and we'll move this bit over hit and B
to see our edges so we can actually see
what's going on that looks and feels
about right to me okay
make sure you save your work and in fact
let's undo that let's not undo that
let's undo that undo okay
and then I'm going to let's get a better
angle on what this thing actually is so
let's find that image I know it's here
somewhere here we go
what a strange piece of geometry I don't
know what that is I think that is this
where you put money this is gotta be
where you put money in wait how does
this even work how does it even work to
be honest I've never tried opening this
is it just free it says free guys come
on
free every Thursday okay so there's no
money slot so maybe this used to be a
money slot I bet you this used to be a
money slot right here and the money the
coins would sit inside of this little
housing I bet you that's what it is so
for the sake of just getting past this
I'm just going to select all these edges
here except for the middle one and I'm
going to hit em T on the keyboard to
extrude these bits in just like that and
I want to make sure I'm making caps so
create caps is checked without it it
just kind of makes like a shell like
this it doesn't actually give it like a
back face so we want that great caps on
and then we want to control a everything
and we want to align our normals which
they already look aligned but let's just
align which made things worse let's try
again align normals nope undo undo let's
just reverse the normals and it looks
like we're good
except for this we will reverse that bit
sweet and let's get that handle in here
this this guy right here so I think the
easiest way to do this would be to make
a plane let's try it let's um let's hold
control with that polygon selected I'm
gonna make a plane and that's gonna
spawn generally right in the place with
the selected polygon so I'm gonna scale
this down with our plane will go 0 0 for
width and height segments let's move it
so it's centered we'll hit our hold
shift to snap the angle of rotation to
90 I'm gonna scale it down I'll hit T
I'll make it editable first and then we
can scale it like this and we'll scale
it in like this and I'm just making this
little the back piece here which
actually lines up pretty darn perfectly
with this gap we created right here and
I'm gonna scale it down so it fits in
that gap just enough like that ok cool
and I'll make sure I'll grab these edges
here and I'll go into a back view front
view is basically the same hit s to snap
the viewport to the current object
selected and I'm going to just bring
in the handles here these edges just
right in there so they fit just nicely
and I'm gonna take this edge hold
control drag it back this way that's
exactly what we want let's take this
edge and we'll control drag it out to
about there cool and we'll move the
whole thing up
saving all right let's grab all of these
polygons ctrl-a imma hit em t again is
the hot key for extrude and we'll
extrude that out just like that
cool let's move it forward
cool now we need to bevel this edge
right here you see this is like more of
a circular deal right here so I'm just
gonna select these two edges 1 & 2 here
and MW is the shortcut for bevel and
it's not working I do not know why
mm-hmm Oh cuz I'm selecting the wrong
okay it's M s naught M W M s is the
shortcut for bevel and you can get the
idea here if we just up the subdivisions
it's 10 or to 5 we should be able to
make a sphere
all right so she's gotta find the right
number here 0.5 inches basically 0.5
inches will do 0.45 and that gets us
right in there sweet and then let's just
start start beveling these things so I
like using bevel modifiers because it
doesn't bake in your bevel it actually
works really nicely so I'm gonna I
noticed that this edge here is beveled a
bit more than this top and bottom edge
so one thing you can do is select that
edge specifically you can even get this
one too it's more on the inside but
whatever and you can go to select set
selection right here I've made a custom
button for it up here you can do that
pretty easily by hitting shift C I'll
type in set selection and you can just
drag it up here
and it'll make it your own little button
you're gonna have to go to window
customize save layout as otherwise it's
not gonna it's not going to stay so
all right so we've made a selection
right well hit set selection you can see
this tag we'll call this it's Ed's edge
selection we'll call it big bevel all
right so let's actually drop in a bevel
modifier so I'll select the plane let's
let's call it um oh we only have two
things called a handle we'll just leave
it as plain for now I'll hold shift and
I'll drop it a bevel modifier in there
and when you hold shift it makes the
modifier or thing that you are selecting
an automatic child of the thing you have
selected so let's go to bevel its RV
it's walked out okay so let's just set
the offset the point one and yeah it's
pretty walked out but here's the thing
there's a little thing here called
selection if you drag this edge
selection into that selection it's only
gonna bevel the things you have selected
and if we want to adjust it like
basically this point here and this bit
there and you just hit set selection
again it's gonna update and then now you
can see how it's updated here and it
looks like it's beveling a little too
far so we'll go point oh five right you
just don't want these intersecting
points that's really gonna ruin your
geometry and make things nasty and we
don't want that subdivision three let's
go subdivision five why not
so that's how you get a nice little
bevel on the edge there and then we also
want to bevel this edge too right so I
think if we hold ctrl and we duplicate
that bevel let's delete the selection
and let's take the offset to 0.03 0.02
and the subdivision can go back down to
like three or something maybe even two
and we just changed the order of this
it's getting you're getting both you're
getting this nice thin one and you're
getting this large one
just changed the order of it right here
in the plane I'm changing the order of
the bevel stack and you can see how it's
it's actually working
it's really cool it's a really cool
trick that I use a whole lot to get
multiple bevels and you can adjust these
all day long you know like if you want
to make your small bevel a little bit
smaller you can go point oh one it's not
baked in that's the best part so we're
gonna do a little bevel run across all
of this so we can kind of control drag
these bevels into these different bits
of geometry so the handle will just name
this coin box for now we can control
drag the small bevel so this is big
bevel and small bevel and let's actually
drag that material on there okay and
here's the difference when it catches
the light here let's compare store
render buffer so we've freezed one side
of the image the other side is live okay
and this has a little bit of bevel to it
so let's actually control drag the small
bevel into the coin box and see what
happens and when we move this slider you
can see how it catches the light a
little bit more this is a I know there's
a better example angle wise for this
kind of stuff but let's zoom in here and
this is very boxy someone changed the
Phong bail you to like Fulani maybe
maybe it's just no falling value
yeah 14 is fine and you see I was
catching the light right here right in
there and without the bevel there's no
light catch so you're getting these nice
details coming out because of the bevel
and that's the only way there's no such
thing as a 90-degree edge there's no
such thing as a sharp edge in real life
even on a handmade custom butcher knife
no such thing
yeah you see that light cat right there
without the bevel no such thing you want
that in there for sure
so we're getting some weird geometry
business here on the front side of this
coin box I'm gonna solo it to see what's
actually going on oh it's cuz I think we
need to optimize it so we're getting
this weird issue where it's not doing
anything here when we uncheck use angle
it's actually cutting into the model and
you'll see that a lot when things are
not optimized so we're going to select
all hit you oh it's gonna optimize and I
don't think it did the trick did not do
the trick I think it's probably because
my geometry is a little little jacked up
here which is why you want to be working
as cleanly as possible because when you
bevel this kind of stuff you're getting
these errors it's probably because
probably didn't do the best modeling job
here so let's actually go into the coin
box let's delete this face here I'm
gonna delete these inside faces ul for
loop selection which is not working so
let's go manual just delete that
and we'll delete that
and that so now it's more of like a yeah
there we go
and I think we can take these edges here
ul for loop selection and that's working
now and we're gonna move this stuff back
a little bit and let's actually close
the polygon hole that we have made right
in here right-click and closed polygon
hole there you are and hopefully the
bevel should work now and there you go
sure enough totally works that's great
and I'm gonna change the bevel let's go
point oh four so it's a little larger a
bit more pronounced sweet that looks
great
back in let's go to our top okay so
let's take the top I'm gonna control
drag the small bevel and then let's solo
it to make sure things are happening all
right so it's separated it once again
Oh weird Ron I think something happened
yes I duplicated at the top now if I
select the top and I go to edge mode I
control a and let's hit yuo to optimize
sometimes this works in this case it
does not we might have to do a custom
bevel on this because our geometry our
geometry is I think it can just be
cleaner I think that's the whole point
is like really get punished for not
having a clean geometry in cinema 4d
which is why a lot of people do not like
modeling in cinema 4d a lot of people
work in fusion 360 and it's a program
that I am in desperate need to learn I
got it downloaded here fusion 360 I'd
love to do tutorials for you guys but
I'm just not there yet because in fusion
360 you don't have to worry about proper
modeling technique you don't have to
spend all this time getting it perfect
and exact because in this case our
bevels not working so it complicates
things
fusion 360 allows you to not to worry
about that stuff but in this case we're
worrying about that stuff so let's go to
edge mode and let's just do this
manually for the top here okay let's
just try geez
let's try selecting everything let's hit
em s yeah all right and it's not working
because we don't Oh idea idea idea angle
threshold crank it
dang it I thought that would work
it's like we only want
we only want like this bit this bit this
bit this bit this bit this bit let's try
it let's try doing that MS that's kind
of what we want yeah that's basically
what we want so maybe what we do is we
go around and we grab the edges we know
we want to be beveled
cool right in there and I'm holding
shift to select multiple edges here
and we only want to bevel these bits and
we'll do that set selection trick again
with the bevel modifier that way we can
change it if we'd like
okay so set selection awesome let me
control drag this and add this to the
set selection right here so we'll click
set selection again let's turn that on
and we will add the selection tag to the
selection box and it looks like that is
doing what we want it to do and I'm
going to can we crank 0.06 maybe yeah I
think we can sweet
and we'll take the top and we'll just
move it up a hair cuz it looks like this
little bit is peeking through yeah and
there you go catching the light very
nicely sweet now let's go to our main
piece and let's bevel this guy I think I
mean who knows at this point let's try
control dragging the small bevel into
main and it looks like it's working for
the most part I think we're good to just
call it right here
we'll use the angle threshold here and
work that slider because you know like
this bit here doesn't need to be beveled
that's just wasted geometry so we'll
we'll just crank that a little bit and
it looks like it's working nicely let's
take that to 0.06 maybe 0.0 0.1 and
we'll take the Phong down to 15 about 14
yes
I think the Fung for all of this stuff
can go to 14 for the most part just
because it's all pretty flat the Phong
will basically affects like how the
light I don't know exactly but it
affects how the lighting works if I
compare let's store the render buffer
the Phong is at 4 angle of 14 right now
which is correct if it goes to 16 it
just kind of makes it look more bulbous
you see how it changes the light how the
light hits this thing it makes it more
like around in bulbous which is not what
we want we want it to be angular and
sharp so set your phone to whatever you
need to set it to so that you get the
desired effect so I should probably do
the same for the coin box should
probably go to 14 as well it is 14 great
and the plane the handle should be 14
cool
all right let's do the hood next all
control drag the small bevel into the
hood and we'll solo it to see what's
going on will zoom in here and it looks
like things are working as they should
thank goodness checking all these edges
here yeah it looks nice let's set the
following angle to 14 as well
awesome awesome
looks good ok moving on we'll do the the
door let's go into the door and let's
control drag the small bevel into the
door and we'll solo this and make sure
we got things right let's go 0.04 for
the bevel so it's a little larger great
we have that line here it's exactly what
we want these seams and this looks good
let's set the phone again to 14 and I'm
wondering do we need to go further yeah
I think 14 is good 12 12 for this bit
cool door hinge mount what is that I
remember what that is
oh this bit okay door hinge mount yeah
it's gonna need a bevel as well so
holding shift at the bevel modifier
0.042 subdivisions is totally fine and
we'll set the fong to fourteen no 1212
it is you see it when it pops just pops
a little bit you can see the difference
here then it'll pop boom nice alright
moving on
the hinge this hinge I believe can just
stay it's not as those grooves aren't as
deep as I'd like I'm wondering if I can
just select it and not scale on the Y I
wonder could I I wonder could I grab all
of these hit T I don't think object per
object manipulation yes okay it looks
like it is working great so I'm just
going to go down the line select all of
these and then scale them all up a
little bit more
hit T and we'll scale those up a little
bit larger and I think we can even scale
them in nope that doesn't work okay
we tried sweet okay let's just give it a
bit more room so I want to go into a
side view we'll move this up in model
mode and then we'll take the door hinge
mount go to point mode grab those guys
make sure we have only select visible
elements unchecked
that's unsolo so we have how do I get
out of this let's unsolo everything wait
what what is going on
I think I can just do this by eye
geometry where you at door hinge mount
yeah we'll just move it up like that
perfect so now it's a bit more defined
in here it feels a little bit better
great let's go to this handle
we already basically basically finished
let's go down here and work on this base
let's bottle bevel this base here so
we'll do base holding shift let go on
bevel we'll set that to 0.05 subdivision
3 so we got a nice nice little base
there and we'll do the Phong will try 14
looks like 10 is working but you don't
wanna go too far because you'll get this
look here if you look in the renderer
he's seeing it see every little bit of
these polygons that's what the Fung is
doing is kind of blending a lot of stuff
together so if I go up to 11 eventually
you'll see it kind of close off and you
just need to ride that line 14 15 16 we
need to go further further
there it is you guys can see hopefully
this is like closing off and we're
losing those hard edges right there at
27 so I'll just go back to 40 and you
can see with and without a Phong Tighe
what it's actually doing so you can see
everything
it looks like the what is it that that
giant structure outside of a Epcot you
know looks like that but when you add
the Phong back on it kind of smoothes it
out so we'll leave that as is and then
we have the base here which has a little
bit of bevel to it as well right in here
so let's just get in there on the stand
will control drag that bevel in and
let's take it up to 0.08 let's go point
one and for some reason it's not getting
this edge here and I'm wondering if
that's because of the way we modeled it
I wonder
hmm it's working on the bottom but not
on the top maybe we take the stand we go
to polygon mode control a we hit you oh
and it optimize it and that still
doesn't work
strange okay let me just try a loop
selection
let's try deleting it well okay I
deleted everything what the heck
and let's try closing the polygon hole
perhaps or bridging it let's try
bridging it bridge tool yes one two
three and four and now it should work
and it does so I guess something was
just up with the way we modeled that
again another reason to model in fusion
360 but you know some of us only have
one program for me it's just one program
right now I'll do everything in cinema
so yeah we got a nice little box here
let's um let's add those screws and call
it because we're basically at that point
right now and I got a P and we got to
announce the weekly challenge winners
and announced the new challenge so let's
add these screws and call it a day guys
so down here it looks like we're dealing
with something pretty simple let's do a
cylinder will scale it down
we'll bring it over to the edge here
scale down something like that
and we'll give this eight sides so
instead of 16 rotational segments we'll
give it a TRO tation 'el segments and
we'll probably make two different styles
of screw here let's take the height
segments we'll do one let's see to make
it editable now in fact let's give it a
Filat or a fillet of 0.04 is totally
fine okay and we'll make that editable
all right so we baked in our bevel which
is fine in this case now with the
cylinder selected if you hold ctrl and
make another no we don't how we do we do
let's make another cylinder let's scale
it down using t i'll get the height
we'll scale it down bring it up take our
original cylinder get it right in there
and it looks like this cylinder let's
give it one height segment let's make it
editable we'll go to edge mode ul for
loop selection T for scale we'll bring
that in and down and you see how it
looks like kind of bulbous that's
because of the Phung technically that
should be look looking kind of straight
so let's try 22.2 let's just bring it
down until boom there it snaps 22.2 oh I
know why it's because yes okay that's
because I just messed up the geometry
here um let's take the faces here ul and
we'll bring those down like that awesome
very nice and let's give it just one
more level of detail control drag to
duplicate scale down and just drop it
right in there just like that and we'll
group all this together all right you
can see that's going way down that that
first bolt
so let's actually fix that it's editable
will go to point mode rectangular
selection we'll get all of those points
and we'll drag them up until we can't
see them anymore we'll make all of these
what alt G to group them we'll call this
bolt one and we want the anchor point to
be right at the bottom so I'm gonna go
in a side view
and we won the second point to be right
there at the bottom so I'm going to use
the axis Center tool with Y all the way
down to negative 100 include children
use all objects execute and it's gonna
get it right there and let's make sure
it's sitting flush boom on top at the
bottom of this thing so let's get those
four corners
right in here and I'm controlled
dragging these and it's not I'm not
being too specific with where they go
because they're bolts and they can have
some random bits to them I'm going to
rotate them randomly to
awesome
very nice okay let's get these rivets
here on the side we have we have a
couple different bolts here there's this
kind of style
there's the screw style so we'll quickly
make a screw and I'm actually gonna show
you guys a little trick that I learned
it's called I guess volume I'm gonna use
the volume measure in the volume builder
you guys will see how I do that instead
of using a boolean which gets really
nasty let's just make a new scene let's
go with a sphere and we'll make it a
hemisphere just like this and I'm gonna
use make it editable in fact let's give
it 32 segments I know 16 is fine
they're gonna be tiny I'll make it
editable scale it down just a little bit
for a screw and we want a plus sign we
want to make a plus signs so that would
be a cube will scale it down move it up
and we'll take this cube
we'll make it editable we'll select all
four sides ul we're gonna extrude these
with MT but we don't want let's see
preserve groups unchecked so it's a plus
sign for that screw okay
we're gonna scale it way down so it fits
right in there like a screw and we'll
move it down right inside okay so we're
gonna use the volume builder and then
the volume measure you'll see here it's
really cool so we'll do volume builder I
think is the first one we use and we
gonna we're gonna drop both of those in
there and it's gonna turn it to this
like pixelated kind of look here this
polygons look and we want to go in here
at the voxel size let's just say 0.5 and
the higher you get the crazier it gets
if I go to the queue if I go to the
sphere actually let's put it inside of a
turbosmooth yep and then the volume
builder let's go point to point five is
okay for now let's take the volume
builder let's go to the volume builder
and we have these two objects in here we
have our subdivision surface which is
our sphere and our cube we want our cube
on top and we want to subtract it and we
should be able I want it to be thick so
let's go to our sphere and I think we
just need to close this hole here so let
me try that closed polygon hole and now
it should let's actually let's see if
that works it does yes it does you can
see that there boom so that's our screw
now how do we how do we get it from this
like voxel-based kind of look to to a
nice smooth geometry so basically the
volume builder you're gonna hold alt and
you're gonna put it inside of a volume
measure right so that's gonna do that's
gonna do a thing there and the volume
measure see it's actually pretty we
should get our subdivision surface back
on our sphere there so that's gonna
that's gonna work for us that's gonna do
the trick here I think the cube is a
little thick so maybe what we do is
scale the whole thing down minus the Y
depth right there and we just pull out
those edges there
we have probably to do these one at a
time so we'll go one and two we'll scale
them out like this and then the other
sides will go out like that as well
cool cool fantastic and then I think we
can just make it editable hit C and we
get this high poly super nice-looking
screw here if you want you can probably
drop it into a I think there's one that
like polygon reduction let's try that
let's drop into a polygon reduction it's
thinking down here in the bottom left
and then it gives us this nasty looking
thing which we will delete and not worry
about so let's copy this screw and go
back to our to our scene here we'll
paste it its massive will scale it way
down bring it up and we'll figure out
where to place these things so we have
three on this side three on that side
and I'm just going to use it across the
bottom too so we want to get it right in
place
we want it having have it sitting flush
did I get the angle right again I did
let's scale it way down awesome
and that goes down here and I'm gonna
make instances of these here so I'm
actually going to where were the
instance bees it up in here feel like
where are you instance there you are
instance will make an instance of the
volume measure that way I think it just
keeps a multi-instance yeah that way it
keeps all the polygon counts down which
is what we want and you can see it here
in the render but not in the viewport
there's probably a way to change that
viewport option should be object let's
render instance I'll keep it as instance
and we'll switch it back to render
instance once everything is placed right
so we're gonna go to town on this and
I'm looking at this reference here just
off frame to get these bolts in the
right position
awesome
set those the multi-instance so it keeps
our viewport smooth but you can see it
here in the renderer and I want to make
sure yeah they're kind of sinking in so
let's fix that we'll go to side view
we'll set these back to render instance
and you want to make sure that these are
sitting flush on top
sweet
so let's alt G all these screws will
call these screws will all G the bolts
those are bolts awesome and we keep
going you know we got some bolts up here
let's just put one down here actually we
don't have that but that's fine so let's
grab a screw and control drag that up
here and I want to make sure my screws
are randomly rotated
so I'll just randomly kind of rotate
these guys and I actually just figured
this one out for the first time
basically if you select the screw
instead of having to get the exact right
Mouse on the wheel right there
I'm just unchecking X and z rotation
whoa yes I'm just unchecking X and z
rotation which allows me to come in here
and just kind of spin spin these things
like crazy and not have to worry about
getting the right axis all right let's
make sure I know there's some one set
yep there's ones on the side here so
let's just actually copy the bolt and
and kind of adjust the bolt here to make
this third and final bolt there's these
rivets in here too let me just lay these
things in four days in fact I might just
not worry about it
and say you guys get the point you know
you'll want to add those bolts and
rivets and stuff because that stuff
really adds to the model and it takes it
to the next level so I'll probably be
texturing this thing over the next day
or two and I'll be posting updates in
the discord server if you guys aren't a
part of that please consider joining
it's down in the description below and
it's a great place for all of us to post
our work show our work together and join
the weekly challenge which is what I'm
super excited about because I got
winners for you guys I have winners to
announce and I have a new challenge to
announce for you so that you guys can
join along and have your work featured
here live on the stream guys so that's
the idea guys we we're modeling this
thing and again I'm doing a presentation
at sea graph and it is a virtual
presentation because you know
coronavirus and everything we're not
going into sea graph they're not holding
these conventions so this is based on a
tutorial that I'm gonna be doing for
that sea graph presentation at the end
of July and it's basically
how to create photo real objects and
composite them in to your live-action
plates and it's about all the secrets
and the tricks and of the trade to get
from nothing to something and something
really cool and awesome and totally
believable for that photo CG or that
photo real CG kind of workflow so you
guys got the little inside scoop here
this will be what I'm putting into this
footage here I'll probably make it blue
and I'm gonna put it right there right
in the middle between these two you know
and I want to get to the point where you
cannot tell the difference between the
real one and the fake one that's the
point of the C graft presentation and
walk you through how I do that hopefully
I'll be able to post that video on this
channel - that'd be awesome so without
further ado guys let's talk about the
weekly challenge winners here the
challenge was to create a jellyfish
simple as that create a jellyfish and
you guys did a really really good job
let's just jump right into it let's get
these winners announced okay let's see
let's see hmm
I got a navigate here alright so guys
for our first winner it was actually the
very first submission and I knew I knew
from the moment he submitted this that
it was a winner okay so it's uh this art
here by damdi super super cool I really
like the lighting that you have here
this internal glow I think works really
really well and you have this nice fall
off here with the glow up here like the
subsurface scattering is really nice
very well done I like your colors I
think you did a fantastic job here on
this material you modeled this perfectly
really really really well done job here
this is awesome this is a really nice
phone background so if you guys
want this piece of art have it as your
phone background it's gonna be on the
discord server in the challenge winners
Channel right after this stream so
congrats damdi you have won the
challenge winner what are they called
it's like a roll the challenge winter
roll on the discord server Congrats next
up we have I guess his name is jellyfish
lovey taco or maybe that's the name of
the art but or it's lovely taco is
probably the guy's name but this is
awesome this is super cool kind of
reminds me of like a half life style
suit but it's the like spaceman slash
underwater diver version look at the
surface imperfections here super nice
great work here on the jellyfish these
are some spongebob style jellyfish it
looks like this is great your emissive
light textures are fantastic the hair
here on the edges are really nice it's
transparent it's it's blurry where it
needs to be like this is super super
cool and it's very well composed and
well lit too so congrats lovely taco I
assume is your name congratulations for
winning the challenge this week I think
you did a great job you totally earned
it this is this is awesome I love
everything about this the color yeah
it's really nice really really nice
Congrats next up we have a painting this
one is not a render this is a painting
guys we're trying to get you know as
long as we get creative and you work on
on the creative crafts that you love
doing and want to get better at that's
the whole point of this creative
challenge it doesn't have to be a
cinema4d the only challenge this could
be anything guys as long as you follow
the rules and make some awesome art
salumi congratulations you painted this
really cool jellyfish this is nice super
nice
so let me used reference images but did
not trace anything absolutely like we're
not here to trace stuff guys
is straight from the dome this is super
cool I love all of this looks like you
did this in Photoshop or something but
man that yeah this is super cool I feel
like the only thing you can go in here
and use like pure white to touch up some
of these points here and really get some
nice highlights maybe up top here like
maybe it's being lit from the top so you
get these nice crispy white highlights
at the top or on the inside maybe get
these crispy white lines coming down
here from the you know from these bits
around the tips here give it a shot
I think it could be pretty cool but
regardless Zulu me congratulations for
winning the challenge this week with a
painting this is freaking cool man keep
it up I love your work please keep it up
two more all right
two more winners we have KF Hammond with
the jellyfish here this is cool this was
between one other piece of art and this
one eventually pulled through as a
winner because there's a little bit of
story going on look you got this kid
here looking into the jellyfish tank
I've been this kid I've been here before
so congrats on giving it a bit more
context you you gave it context you gave
it a little bit of story and I like that
and I really like the jellyfish here
this is cool again this is kind of like
a sponge Bobbi style jellyfish very nice
very very nice
maybe you can use a little bit more
samples back here it looks a little
grainy or something but otherwise I
think it's nice I think it's very nice
and I almost wonder like this color here
if there's a little dull to me I'm
wondering if you can commit to more of
like a an orange or something or a
yellow and brighten it up a little bit
it just feels a little dull that's it
but overall I really like your
composition and I like your colors and I
like your lighting so hey
congratulations KF Hammond
on winning this week's weekly challenge
and last one here for you guys this guy
wins these challenges a lot his work is
very good so without further ado the
last winter visual with this beautiful
work of art here I love your colors on
this this turquoise with the skin tone
is absolutely beautiful it looks like
you got the hair looking real nice too
this is fantastic jellyfish looking good
yeah your colors in your composition and
your lighting like everything just looks
really nice I know visual it uses I
believe 3ds Max and Arnold I think for
his work some of the other work today
was seen about cinema 4d some the other
work was blender so guys again it
doesn't matter what program you use it
just matters how you use it right that's
it so visual Congrats to you and the
rest of the challenge winners this week
for winning this week's weekly challenge
alright guys so if you want to catch
these works of art definitely join the
discord server check them out you know
let everyone know congratulations
putting in the hard work and everything
so for this next weekly challenge for
this week's weekly challenge I'm gonna
leave it to you guys here in the live
chat okay what do you guys want to do
for a weekly challenge this week think
about it go ahead and at me here in the
live chat so I can see that you're
talking about the weekly challenge okay
what do you want to create when you want
to get good at what do you want to work
on what do you want to challenge
yourself with this week while you guys
are doing that I'm use the restroom and
I'll be back in like two minutes I'll
see you guys soon
you
all right
hopefully you guys have decided let's
figure it out let's go through all of
these recreate a famous painting indoor
renders a museum maybe post-apocalypse
scene completely made-up and somewhat
nonsensical product oh that's funny okay
a fake product maybe something about an
astronaut in space there are many things
you could do
Zen garden fluid so far I'm liking fake
product fake product and Zen garden
those are the two that I'm feeling what
do you guys think between Zen garden and
fake product
well can I do that can I create a poll
here um I don't know how hmm no Asad
we're not doing Mars we did planets last
time nice try though
Asad you're gonna get booted here if you
keep saying Mars we're not doing Mars um
send garden okay Zen garden I'm seeing a
lot of Zen garden fake part of a product
fake product saying garden okay so it's
kind of a split hmm let's go with fake
products guys because I think I didn't
done anything like that before
we've done some Zen garden again do a
Zen garden for sure but fake product
sounds like a lot of fun so that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna do a fake
product so it's got to be a picture it's
got to be one render product shot it's
got to be a product shot of a fake
product it can be a product to be
whatever product just got to be a fake
product that's it
it'll be judged on the detail of your
render or the quality let's say rather
the quality of your render your lighting
your framing you know your presentation
how legit does it look and we'll also be
judged on the fake product you come up
with you know is it something that we
actually need is it something ridiculous
it could be whatever but just make sure
it's a fake product and have fun with it
make it look nice light it like a nice
product shot you know when does it do
good question it's due next week
Saturday at 9 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
so that I have enough time to like look
through them and
choose the winner you guys have one week
to do this week's weekly challenge which
is a fake product should be a render a
product render of a fake product due
next week hopefully that's good right
can you guys hear that yeah fake product
you got to make it yourself cannot be a
real thing
cannot be a real product it's gotta be a
fake product that is the that is the
challenge the point of the challenge
cannot be something that already exists
that's nearly three how long do we go
for three and a half hours Wow almost
four hours my throat hurts I need water
I need chapstick I'm gonna see you guys
this week in the discord server get on
it if you're not already if you guys
like this video please subscribe if
you're still hanging out I I appreciate
you you've hung out with me for four
hours making a newspaper stand all right
that means a lot so if you guys like
these please subscribe to this channel
I'll be posting a whole bunch more of
this for the rest of the year when we
doing this we learning together that's
the whole point getting good at stuff we
want to get good at together yeah leave
a comment down below if you have
anything that you want to learn any
tutorials that you'd like to learn again
I'm learning Unreal Engine I want it to
the point where I can stream Unreal
Engine and teach you guys all the things
I'm learning yeah if you guys want any
other things in c4d please just let me
know leave a comment and again join the
discourse server I'll see you guys there
this week in the meantime you guys have
a good one and I will be working hard on
the next corridor digital video the
Dominos video man there's a lot of the
effects going on that one what else
anything else yeah still working on that
HDRI tutorial let me show you let me
show you a render that I did from the
HDRI tutorial
so right here we got the the fake shadow
mixed with the real shadow in here we
got some bounce light from the sphere
coming hitting the bottom down here we
got some glow and this is just to show
you guys the power of custom HDRI images
yeah obviously there's no ball there
there's no shadow there this is the
original footage shadow laid in
perfectly matched with the real shadow
and then all the rest of this added in
on top in the beautiful 4k and I'm gonna
try and get this out by the end of the
month here for you guys okay that's my
goal so think of me it's gonna be a
tough month it's gonna be tough rest of
the month so I'll see you guys on the
other end all right peace
have a good one have a good Saturday
have a good Sunday have a good weekend
alright guys peace out later